Perfect.
Cool.
So, my name is Johnny.
I'm a staff engineer in Washington, D.C.
Working at a company called morning consult.
And today I want to talk to you about a very
bikesheddyworthy topic, which is finding your
abstractions sweet spot.
So, moving right along, this begs the question:
What exactly is an abstraction?
Before we get into that, though, I want to
talk just a little bit about simplicity and
complexity.
So, we've all heard the mantra: Keep it simple,
stupid.
And truth be told, other than being a bit
rude, I think it's a bit misguided as well.
The fact of the matter is, simple doesn't
really scale.
It's really easy to get that hello world up
and going and, you know, the first couple
months of the thing you're trying to build,
it's really great.
But if you have any amount of success, things
get really big, really complex really quickly.
So, how do you embrace this idea of simplicity
while accounting for inevitable complexity,
right?
So, we don't want KISS.
What I tend to think about is elegance.
Right?
I think this is what we really mean when we
say to keep things simple.
Right?
Elegance I define as complexity expressed
simply.
And the goto metaphor I tend to use is if
you think about all of our reality, all the
space and all that, it exists, right?
There are trillions and trillions of protons
and photons whatnot in the universe.
They come together to form everything you
see around you, stars and planets and meteors.
And even you and I, living organisms.
That's a hugely complex system.
But it's really interesting that all of reality
as we understand it today can also be expressed
in the language of mathematics.
That's an incredibly elegant thing.
We don't know why.
There's a big argument in, you know, physics
about, you know, whether math is real, whether
it's not.
You know?
Do you discover math?
Or do you invent it?
That's a completely different talk out of
the realm of my particular expertise.
But I think it's really elegant, nonetheless.
Don't keep it simple.
Keep it elegant.
So, with that said, what is an abstraction?
In this context, I like to think about an
abstraction as the degree to which complexity
is encapsulated.
And going a little bit deeper here, I like
to think about things in terms of strong and
weak abstractions.
When you think about a strong abstraction,
it encapsulates a lot of complexity.
And this is not necessarily a good thing.
Right?
There are many times when you don't necessarily
want to hide a ton of complexity.
When you want to maximize the amount of flexibility
you give people who consume your APIs.
And we'll talk a little bit about that later.
Conversely, a weak abstraction encapsulates
very little complexity.
And pejorative to the term weak itself, this
is not necessarily a bad thing.
Sometimes you actually need people to be able
to get down to the nuts and bolts of what
you're providing them because that's what
they need in order to be able to build something
on top of your platform.
Games seem to be really popular this year
at JSConf.
And I swear I put this up before I saw all
the other games that were available.
So, this is gonna be called guess the API.
So, essentially the way it works, I'm gonna
show you a small code snippet and then you're
going to use context clues to figure out which
famous JavaScript API invokes this implementation.
So, we'll go through an example real quick.
If I were to show you this block of code,
you'd look at it, pick up some context clues.
You know, you see the word "App," create application,
all this good stuff.
Does anyone have any idea where this block
of code comes from?
Oh, if you have any idea if you wrote this
code, you are not allowed to participate.
And if you cheat, may your life be filled
with misery forever.
[ Laughter ]
Anyone?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [ Away from microphone ]
JOHNNY: Express application.
But specifically, which function?
That's all right.
You were right.
It's basically when you invoke express itself
at the root, right?
So, that's the only example I have.
The others aren't going to be that easy.
I picked stuff without revealing docs, but
you get the point, right?
All right.
Ready?
Here's the next one.
Picking up context clues.
There's some event stuff in here, some listener
stuff.
Anyone want to take a stab?
Event on, that's pretty good.
Yeah.
This is whenever anyone in Node uses an event
emitter and calls a .on event, that's what's
invoked.
Most notably in strings, but also when you're
creating HTTP servers and things like that.
What about this one?
This one might be a little bit easy.
This is props in a particular library all
over the place.
React what?
React dot?
Right.
React.createelement.
So, somebody's mad.
So, what's the point here?
The point is to illustrate that, you know,
with some context clues you can kind of get
an idea of what's going on.
But the fact of the matter is, there's like
nothing wrong with this code itself.
You know, unless you hate semicolons or whatever.
But the idea is that I wanted to illustrate
the entropy that's involved in creating the
abstractions that you use every day.
Someone had to write so you can essentially
write this.
This doesn't just apply to code either.
When you think about abstractions and what
they're useful for, they're all over the place.
Most notably, when we think about infrastructure,
right?
This is a big thing that's been happening
within the industry really for about the last
ten years.
A lot of innovation has been happening.
But really the last few years is when things
really heated up.
And I want to talk a bit about going up the
abstraction chain to kind of figure out to
kind of illustrate exactly why these things
are important and the big milestones that
we've seen.
So, for those of us who were around when you
needed to essentially have access to a physical
server to actually deploy something.
Whether it's a website or whatever you.
This was a very imperative workflow to actually
get your stuff deployed, right?
Needed to know a lot of things.
You needed to know where the server was.
You needed to know security considerables
to get into the server.
You needed to know where on the server to
put your deployable artifacts.
It was a very, very imperative thing.
And when say you need to know where it was,
sometimes that was just in your bedroom, right?
So, moving forward a little bit, someone had
a great idea to just use virtual machines.
The idea is like, forget the hardware, but
I do need a computer.
And so, began this whole revolution of computer
emulation.
A whole level of abstraction that was really
a game changer in terms of portability.
For the first time, really the thing on which
your application rely wasn't necessarily the
host operating system on which your stack
actually ran.
And this was huge.
So, moving up a little bit, we talk about
containers a bit, right?
Forget the computer, all I really need are
compute resources, right?
This is about compute resource emulation,
right?
I don't need a UI.
I don't need a start menu, that's kind of
dumb.
What I really need is a file system, CPU and,
you know, memory.
Other stuff.
And that's what I need to run my application.
And so, the abstraction gets a bit stronger.
Platform as a service.
This was really great as well because it allowed
you to not even have to think about what your
application was running on.
That was irrelevant most of the time, right?
And there are caveats here as well.
But the idea is, the only thing you ship is
an application.
And someone else worries about everything
else.
That was your interface to your deployments.
Right?
Forget the compute resources, mostly, here's
my app running.
Which brings us to the current revolution,
which is serverless, right?
Forget the application and the computer.
I'm gonna ship business logic.
I want you to take care of essentially everything
else.
And that's kind of where we are now.
And you see this continuously evolving and
getting more and more strong as an abstraction.
And you see where the benefits are for getting
things up and running really closely.
But you also encounter situations where these
strong abstractions don't really make sense.
Other people really need to use other things.
So, what can go wrong?
Well, short answer is: A lot.
So, breaking changes.
When you're not focusing on thinking about
this up front, at least to some extent, you
really run the risk of having a lot of breaking
changes occur when you are developing your
software, right?
And you end up with nonbackwards compatibility
software which forces you to essentially abandon
users or have a lot of support over a long
time.
And truth be told, too many breaking changes
is gonna prevent you from being able to sell
to large enterprise customers.
They're very risk averse.
If you think about customers like the government
or people in highly regulated industries like
the finance industry or whatnot, they will
not use your software if it's not stable.
Tech debt.
You could go the other direction, right?
If you decide to keep those major versions
in place, but you still need to make a lot
of changes, you're going to have to do a lot
of contorting in order to be able to maintain
that backward compatibility.
We've all worked in those codebases where
we didn't want to break anything or we absolutely
couldn't break anything, but we needed to
make fixes.
This created a lot of tech debt in the weight
and there was no clear path to actually cleaning
it up without essentially a complete refactor
or rewrite.
User confusion.
So, this one is a bit less obvious.
But if you get your abstraction wrong, or
if it's not ideal, there's gonna be a lot
of confusion within the communities that consume
your software.
I remember back when the AngularJS 1 landed,
and it was absolutely a game change fetor
frontend environment.
And I remember they demonstrated the twoway
data binding and it was like amazing.
And this was great.
But then something happened.
I guess about 24 months had gone by.
Companies had started adopting AngularJS as
like, you know, something that was real.
And then people actually started building
really big, robust web applications using
AngularJS.
And then what happens is, you get to a place
where you need to make a deployment or you're
getting close to the end.
But you have some last-minute requirement
changes.
It happens all the time.
But you've architected your application in
such a way that your directives need to communicate
with each other in a very elegant way.
But you didn't architect, you didn't account
for this, right?
This is before we had sort, you know before
redux was really a thing and we had like really
mature sort of like state management solutions
on the frontend.
So, what would happen is people would try
to get two directives to talk to each other
very quickly.
And instead of having to refactor the way
the communication messaging happened, they
would adopt what I refer to as the spray and
pray architecture.
And you take advantage of Angular's dependency
injection.
You inject root scope and you do a rootscope.broadcast
and throw out data out into the either a hope
something receives.
I know some of you have done it.
You look guilty, heads down.
I know, I have been there.
This was not Angular's fault.
This was the abstraction we were given in
order to build our applications.
And it just so happen when is trying to scale
out he's applications, this was the challenges
we ran into.
In fact, a lot of these issues were some of
the early inspirations for, you know, architect
for libraries like React and Vue, et cetera.
And these are the types of things that can
happen, right?
This is not bashing Angular 1.x.
I'm a big fan.
I don't think it deserves half the flak it
received.
So, the reason you're all here.
Where is my sweet spot?
How can I figure out where I need to be placing
my abstractions such that it benefits both
myself and my users?
So, opinions, opinions, opinions, warning.
So, the big thing I think everyone should
really think about is flexibility versus ease
of use.
Right?
This is the big one.
This is going to be your ultimate tradeoff.
The idea is the more flexible you are, you're
gonna tend to sacrifice some ease of use,
right?
This is gonna be your weaker abstractions
with flexibility.
This is gonna be your low-level stuff.
This is gonna be your WebGLs of the world
which are really great.
But someone like me, not a 3D programmer,
I need something higher level.
I need the 3JSs of the world.
Or higher than that, truth be told.
Versus ease of use, right?
You are a 3D programmer and you really know
what you're doing, a lot of the helpers out
there are just gonna get in your way more
than anything else.
Maybe that's not what you need.
So, what you have to do is figure out where
your users are and make sure you're meeting
them where they are.
Similar to that, you have to consider your
audience, right?
Who are you building for?
Is this internal or external?
Right?
Internal you can get away with a lot of stuff.
If it's external and people are gonna be using
this either as a product or maybe just an
open source tool, you need to make sure that
you have that correct understanding.
What are people using your stuff to build
with?
You can't control that, but it may come into
play.
This is when you really get intimate with
the users and figure out what they're doing.
Platforms.
This is a good one as well.
Some platforms and languages lend themselves
better to certain levels of abstraction.
Practitioners of a language might regularly
work on a certain level, right?
JavaScript developers generally want objects
and strings, that sort of thing.
Maybe some arrays.
Go Lang, they want buffers and errors, have
you looked at go code?
Rust developers want jobs.
Just kidding.
That's a troll.
I love Rust.
It's a great language.
Life span.
This is a big one as well.
Right?
This is very similar to, you know, the breaking
changes.
If you're very up front with your audience
and your users about the type of timeline
they can expect for support, this is gonna
inform the level at which you actually, you
know, write your software.
That's gonna be really important.
So, coming to wrap things up a little bit.
You want to make sure you focus on elegance.
And not just simplicity.
Simplicity won't scale.
No one's gonna buy anything that's simple,
right?
Because anyone can reproduce your work.
If you're gonna be successful, you're gonna
inevitably head towards complexity.
The best thing downing is account for it in
a way that allows you to build a competitive
product.
But also ensures that your users are happy.
Think in terms of weak or strong abstractions
and when is the right time to use either one.
Sometimes you need to support the whole spectrum,
right?
That's something that's really important.
That's gonna take a lot of resources, it's
gonna take a lot of time.
Maybe you start at one end of the spectrum
and you end up on the other.
This is a decision that you have to make.
So, remember the tradeoffs of flexibility
and ease of use.
Very similar to the previous point.
There are real tradeoffs here.
And you need to make them as close to up front
as you can.
But not necessarily completely.
Think about the consequences of getting it
wrong.
Frequent breaking changes, tech debt, user
confusion, there's nothing you can do to avoid
all of these things, unfortunately.
Part of the planning up front is to make sure
that you know that you're gonna accumulate
that tech debt.
So, just have a plan to kind of pay it down,
right?
Or if you're gonna have frequent breaking
changes, maybe you want to launch in a beta
for a while and make sure people understand
that up front.
If you know this is gonna be crazy and maybe
people are gonna be a bit confused, focus
more on developer reach out and make sure
people know exactly how to use your software.
And think about your audience.
you can have the best product and the best
software in the world.
But if no one is going to buy it and no one
wants to use it, then you're essentially dead
in the water.
And with that, thanks.